Huh
that quickly to one.
Boom.
And we're alive.
Mr Polin,
how are you?
Pay Good.
Good to be here this two way.
There you go.
Okay.
What's happening man?
How are you?
Good.
Good to be in la.
Uh,
good to have you here.
I've been a fan of your work for a long
time man.
And I got really excited when I found
out that you were writing a book on
psychedelics and uh,
um,
I'm just,
uh,
I think it's a,
an amazing subject and I'm,
I'm glad someone who's respected
yourself is getting it.
It's a crackpot subject,
right?
It's one of those subjects you're like,
oh no.
Michael Pollan found drugs.
Like what's he doing?
He's having a crisis and you know,
doing mushrooms,
it is a bit of a departure.
I think that there are people who are
expecting another book on food or
agriculture.
We're a little surprised.
Um,
but so far people have been following
me.
You know,
who cared about food and ag and there,
there's more overlap than I ever would
have guessed.
I think you caught the perfect wave.
I think your book is coming out right
when John Hopkins research centers
starting to put out these studies on it
and people are starting to recognize it.
MTMA has amazing results for
posttraumatic stress disorder from
veterans and marijuana is becoming legal
in more and more states.
It's like you're catching this wave.
And I didn't know that.
I,
you know,
you never know where the culture is
going to be.
Cause you started book years before.
How long did you start it?
Well,
I started the research in,
uh,
2014.
I wrote a piece for the New Yorker
called the trip treatment,
uh,
which is online.
Um,
and it was my first foray into this
work.
I went down to Hopkins.
It's been a lot of time at Nyu.
And at the time they were doing this
really interesting trial where they were
giving psilocybin to people with cancer
diagnoses,
many of whom were terminal.
And that seemed like such a weird idea
to me that I,
I was curious to explore it.
And I spent a lot of time talking to
patients,
many of whom were dying,
uh,
about how this single high dose silicide
been experience a guided silicide and
experience.
And we should talk a little bit about
how the guided changes things for,
you know,
it's not the image people have is
popping some mushrooms in your mouth and
maybe go to a concert or going to the
beach.
But this is a very controlled internal
experience,
uh,
completely reset these people's attitude
toward death and it allowed them to die
with equanimity.
And,
um,
uh,
and when these results were published,
um,
just last year,
they found that,
um,
that in 80% of the people who had the
session,
uh,
they had statistically significant
reductions in standard measures of
depression and anxiety.
It was one of the most effective
psychiatric interventions that the
psychiatrist had ever seen.
A,
which is amazing,
a single experience.
And then a molecule could change the
contents of your head to the,
to the extent that you would rethink
your mortality.
Uh,
and so as I began talking to these
people and hearing their stories,
many of which were just remarkable,
I realized,
you know,
this is not just an article.
There's a book here and there's,
so,
you know,
there are two kinds of articles you
write as a journalist.
One is you f you,
you're sick of the topic by the time you
finished and you can't wait to be done.
And the other is,
God,
I just scratched the surface.
And this was one of those.
Did you have any experiences personally
with psychedelics before you wrote this?
Very Limited,
um,
I,
for some peculiar reason,
never did psychedelics in college.
They just weren't around.
I went into the round,
no,
I went to the wrong school and I was
like a very kind of progressive hippie
school.
I went to Bennington college in Vermont
and there were,
there was lsd there before me and there
was lsd after me.
But I was in this little wrinkle in time
where there was only alcohol.
I need a cut there guys.
Thanks Jamie.
Crazy only alcohol in college and I
hadn't,
so I had no experience of psychedelics.
Uh,
until I was in my late twenties,
and then it was,
um,
pretty mild.
I had a couple of mushroom experiences
that would,
I now describe as the aesthetic
experiences,
right.
Once small doses,
they were,
yeah.
I don't,
I never measured,
it was probably one gram,
so I'd never had a big trip.
And,
um,
and there was another reason I was,
I didn't feel psychologically sturdy
enough and I came of age just when the,
the,
the scare stories about psychedelics
were everywhere in the culture.
You know,
they would scramble your chromosomes,
you'd stare at the sun until you went
blind.
Um,
you know,
the person who took all the orange
sunshine and thought he was an orange
for the rest of his life,
you know,
these stories are out there.
And I was afraid to,
I was just afraid.
Yeah.
Well that's,
it's,
it's not an unfounded fear.
Oh No,
I'm,
no,
people can really get into psychological
trouble.
I think it's really important that
people understand that a,
it's a,
it's a profound,
powerful,
destabilizing experience.
And depending on your mindset and your,
and the situation in which you take it
set and setting,
it can be I'm ecstatic or horrific.
And um,
and you know,
there are many people who had a series
of very good trips and then they have
that one bad trip.
And uh,
so yeah,
I and I had heard enough stories about
that,
um,
to,
to stay away.
Uh,
so,
so discovering this kind of later in
life,
uh,
you know,
I was certainly not something I planned
on or expected.
It's a
great tragedy and in my opinion that our
culture has demonized these substances
and put them in this category of
forbidden fruit to the point where you,
you,
you're so nervous about doing them,
you have to get him from some shady
character and you don't know where
you're getting.
Yeah.
You have to do them in the,
you know,
in secrecy you have to be really
careful.
But we also at the same time are aware
of all these incredibly positive
benefits from them.
And then if we just had professional
places where we could go to and when we
have these rehab facilities that are
available for people trying to kick
opiates and people trying to get their
life together.
But if we had something similar like a
psychedelic facility with registered
professionals who understand this and
who could evaluate you psychologically
understand if you're perhaps taking
medication that would adversely affect
your trip,
try to find out who you are,
like where,
what state you're at in your life.
Have you had any experiences before?
Maybe you should put you on a low dose,
right?
Hold up slowly.
Let's try something small and see how
you react to it.
And then I think,
I don't think people like myself or pot
smokers or people who've done
psychedelics,
I don't think we do it any favors either
because we're always trying to pretend
that there is no adverse effects and
that there's like,
you know,
people,
when they get into something,
they want everybody to do it.
And I've been guilty of this myself and
people tell us
there's a,
there's a occupational hazard of a,
of a irrational exuberance.
And you know,
this is what happened to Timothy Leary,
right?
I mean,
people have an amazing experience and
the first thing they think is
everybody's got to do this.
But it isn't for everybody.
And I think you're absolutely right.
I think that,
look,
there are risks,
but these are not drugs of abuse,
right?
They're nonaddictive,
they're anti addictive.
The first thought after having a big
psychedelic trip is not,
when can I do this again?
Right?
Any,
whoa.
The last one I had,
I was like,
I don't know if I could do that again.
Yeah.
I just felt that way every time it's
like childbirth or how,
how we here try childbirth is you'd,
you can't imagine doing it again and
eventually you do.
You do do it again.
Um,
so I do think that we have to find the
proper context in which to do it.
And I,
I think your point is really important.
We need trained guides.
Um,
the experience is completely different
when it's guided.
Um,
because you have a sense of safety.
There's someone looking out for your
body while your mind is traveling.
And this allows you to essentially
surrender to the experience.
And most bad trips in my experience are
the result of people resisting what is
happening there.
Ego is dissolving and it's scary.
It feels like a death and they try to
stop it and that can make you very
anxious.
And so all the guides I worked with and
interviewed,
they were all like,
relax your mind and float downstream.
If you see a door open it,
if you see a staircase go down.
It,
um,
uh,
surrender trust and let go.
And this kind of advice changes
everything.
And the chances of a bad trip I think in
a guided situation are substantially
less because they know how to help you
deal with it and what to tell you when
it's happening.
Um,
so I do think that,
um,
by,
by forcing these drugs underground and
into this very kind of unregulated use,
um,
there were not reports of bad trips were
much fewer before the moral panic about
lsd in 1965 and when it was still legal,
um,
you didn't hear about bad trips.
Um,
you started hearing about it when the
culture did this one and turned against
a psychedelic.
So I think you can create situations
where the,
the,
the risks are really mitigated.
Well,
I think also the fear like you were
talking about,
right,
but for the podcast or right as we
started,
what some people worried that they were
going to turn into an orange or think
they're an orange or all those fears.
If you take something and those things
are in the back of your head and your
that you can literally manifest extreme
anxiety that might not have been there
if he just relaxed and just had the
experience alone,
you know,
a on its own without all the cultural
hysteria
attached to it or,
or episodes of paranoia.
That's,
that's common too.
So,
but a good guide can work you through
this.
And actually they don't even like the
term bad trip.
They call it a challenging trip because
often very interesting material comes up
that you then can work on later.
Uh,
it's like having a nightmare and you
know,
analyzing it with your shrink,
it actually may be very productive.
Um,
so,
you know,
I,
I was kind of a nervous nelly going into
this and I really looked at the whole
risk profile and on the,
on the physiological side,
your body,
the risks are remarkably low.
And I'm speaking here of the classic
psychedelics.
I'm not talking about Mtma or even pot.
I'm really,
I'm talking about LSD silicide man,
which is magic mushrooms.
Um,
DMT Mescalin.
they are much less toxic than many of
the over the counter drugs you have in
your medicine cabinet.
There's no lethal dose,
which is remarkable.
There's one elephant that was killed
with LSD once.
They wanted to see what it would take
and it was this,
they gave it a massive dose,
but to get it to the point where they
could administer it,
they had to give it a massive dose of
tranquilizer.
So it isn't actually clear that the LSD
killed it may have been the,
the Benzos or whatever they were given.
I know.
What a horrible thing,
right?
Go online and look up,
uh,
the elephant who died from LSD.
Crazy idea.
Uh,
and when Quincy was going through the
elephants mind before it,
animals don't like psychedelics that
much.
Um,
we know that if you,
you know,
that classic set up that drug abuse
researchers use where they put a rat in
a cage and they had,
there's a lever and they could
administer cocaine or heroin,
uh,
or they can have lunch and they'll press
the cocaine lever till they die.
You put Lsd in that setup,
they press it once and never again.
Well
set up is always screwy,
right,
because they really shouldn't be in that
situation and it's not a natural setup.
Like that's been critical.
That's right.
And there somebody in Vancouver,
these really cool rat park experiments.
Yes,
that's what you're referencing.
And um,
basically they thought that this was
inevitably what happens.
But in fact,
if you give a rat a beautiful cage with
some things to play with some other rats
to hang out with some nature,
you know,
some shrubs and things,
it will not take the cocaine.
And that interesting.
It tells us that environment has a lot
to do with drug addiction.
I think for sure with human beings too.
I mean,
oh,
human beings in these really fruitless
lives that are very,
very frustrating.
I think about the people who came back
from Vietnam.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know if I should say most,
but a very high percentage of,
of the troops in Vietnam were on heroin
when they were there.
They were seemingly addicted.
They were using an all the time and they
got back and only 10% had a problem.
Um,
the others were able to kick it really
easily.
It's very contextual.
It's not all biology,
it's about environment.
Now,
when you were researching this book,
um,
did you,
did you start doing your own personal
experimentation?
Yeah.
Um,
I had a series of trips for the book.
I had become,
for a couple of reasons I'd become very
curious about the people I was
interviewing,
trying to make sense of how they could
have these transformative trips on a
drug,
which seemed implausible to me.
Um,
and,
uh,
I also kind of got jealous of the
experiences they were having.
They were having these big spiritual
experiences.
And I swear,
I don't think I've ever had a spiritual
experience.
I'm kind of spiritually retarded
actually,
or was,
and um,
so I,
I realized at a certain point I had to
see the experience from inside to
describe it in a book.
It's also kind of my brand as a writer
when I wrote about the cattle industry,
I bought a steer when I wrote about
architecture,
I built a house.
I like to get my hands dirty and see
things from inside.
There's a quality of wonder you can
capture doing something for the first
time.
So in a way,
the fact I was psychedelically naive,
I saw as a positive because people
who've,
who really know the territory are not
going to have quite the same first
experience that was going to have.
So that was really helpful.
So I,
um,
I did a few things.
I,
I went,
um,
mushroom hunting with Paul stamets.
Has he been on the show out there?
Yeah,
he's a very cool guy.
He's crazy.
He's totally crazy.
And he took me to a spot where you can
find the strongest silicide been known
to man that he civic northwest.
It's near the mouth of the Columbia
River.
Um,
I can't be more specific than that.
Don't,
you know,
people would their mushroom spots.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
we went hunting.
It was like this,
you know,
uh,
for Lauren December weather and uh,
he took me to this place and uh,
we spent a couple days outside looking
for these mushrooms and we found a salon
Ossipee as your essence,
which he,
he found for the first time and named
after his son is serious.
Oh Wow.
Who in turn is named after the color of
mushrooms when they're bruised as your,
so there's kind of an institute is
committed to fungus.
He's all in.
He is all in wood fungus.
And I was very excited when we found a
couple and they're hard.
I mean,
I would not recommend do,
do it yourself with psilocybin just
because it's not like looking for
Chanterelles and morels.
Right.
There are mushrooms that look exactly
like silicide been that can give you a,
just an agonizing death.
Yeah.
But when you're with Paul stamets,
you feel pretty confident.
Right.
And,
uh,
so we found these and,
he said to me after we'd found them,
we were sitting around the campfire,
we were cooking some dinner outside our
Yurt.
And,
uh,
he said,
yes,
I,
these,
these are almost too strong for me.
I said,
really?
Why?
He says,
well,
they have a side effect that bothers
some people.
I say,
what's that?
Temporary paralysis.
Oh,
I know why that would bother anybody.
So weird.
Yeah,
I know.
Piki Piki Oh my God.
I was a little reluctant to take them,
but I,
I,
so I did,
I had,
uh,
my first deals I had been experienced
since my twenties was a,
and at the time I was like 60 or
approaching 60.
Actually,
I have to be very vague on where all
these things happened,
when all these things happen.
Um,
uh,
and I had a,
a kind of a wonder,
I didn't take a lot of them.
I made a tea and I had a really powerful
experience.
It was very much about being in nature.
I was at our house.
We have a house in New England that
we've had for many years and I was in my
garden and you know,
I've written a lot about plants and I've
written about plant intelligence and
planet consciousness and things like
that.
And I've always believed intellectually
that plants,
domesticated plants are acting on us.
It's,
it's not just,
it's,
it's a two way street.
We change plants,
they change us.
We have been,
um,
uh,
in the same way that say the apple tree
or the flower is manipulating the B,
making it come,
pay attention to it,
offering it nectar and exchange for it,
picking up pollen on its legs and
doesn't even realize what it's really
doing is being tricked by the plant into
pollinating it and caring it's genes
down the street or around the world.
That's happening to us too.
And plants work on us and I,
it's a slightly trippy idea,
but it's just co evolution.
That's how co evolution works.
So in,
during this experience,
I felt that in a way I never had that
idea became flesh.
And I felt that these plants were kind
of looking back at me.
Uh,
and that they were very benign.
They had only good intentions,
but that there were more subjectivities
in my garden than I thought.
You know,
we go through the world thinking we're
the only thinking subject.
Everything else is an object.
One of the things that happens on
psychedelics is everything becomes,
has,
has life in it,
has consciousness in it.
And that was a powerful and beautiful
experience.
And so that was my dipping my toes in.
And then after that I sought a guide
because I was trying to simulate the
experience I was hearing about at
Hopkins and,
uh,
Nyu where they were doing these studies,
not just with the dying,
they were doing it with smokers and
alcoholics and meditators,
all these different groups.
But I didn't qualify to enter into
those.
So I had to go underground.
And one of the things I learned is that
there's this thriving network of
underground guides all over the country.
I don't know how many there are.
Um,
but they're very professional people.
They're not drug dealers.
There are therapists and some of them
are trained psychologists or mds in some
cases actually.
And they're so convinced of the healing
value of these medicines that they're
willing to risk their freedom,
uh,
and their livelihood to work
underground.
So I found my way into this community
and um,
uh,
and,
and interviewed a bunch of people and
some of them were not the kind of people
you want to trust your mind to.
I mean,
and no doubt there are lots of
charlatans.
Everyone I I interview is pretty
professional,
but some of them were just a little too
casual about something I was kind of,
um,
you know,
worried about.
Uh,
there was one guy,
I remember this Romanian Psycho naut
therapist in his seventies,
who,
uh,
I said,
well,
what happens if something bad happens?
You know,
what if,
what if somebody dies,
you know,
while they're with you getting this
trip?
And he said,
you bury them with all the other people
and that,
that kind of casualness really troubled
me.
So I didn't work with him.
Um,
but eventually I found people that I,
uh,
I trusted and I had a bond with and I
had some very powerful,
uh,
experiences with them and uh,
that did change me,
uh,
in ways that I'm still kind of,
you know,
digesting
now.
I would like to see you back to the
garden thing when you're having this
experience with these plants.
I had a experience once on very high
dose of marijuana edibles.
I went into a grow room that uh,
this,
uh,
local dispensary had set up.
It's just big room filled with plants
and it was the first time I like when I
walked in,
it's the first time I've ever been
around pot plants where I felt like they
are aware that I was there.
It was very strange.
It you,
you had this weird feeling of them
having much more sensitivity than you
imagined that they are aware of you.
But as you said,
they're benign and they just sort of
sitting there.
But it was almost like they were saying
hello to me or that they recognize that
I could tune into them because I was so
barbecue that I was,
I was on their wavelength.
When you're out there with those plants
and you said that you felt consciousness
from them now as an intelligent,
rational person,
did you start pondering whether or not
you,
we're just perceiving this because it
was convenient and you were
hallucinating and adding all this
contextual weirdness to this situation?
I,
you know,
I'm sure I was projecting things.
I went to them,
but,
but I've looked at this question and the
science of it pretty closely.
Right?
And how you define consciousness matters
here,
but plants are conscious in the sense of
they're aware of their environment.
They have senses.
They're not like our senses,
right?
They're picking up on chemicals in the
air and in the soil and light in very
specific ways.
And they're reacting not just
instinctually,
but appropriately.
There are experiments that show the
plants can learn in some primitive way.
So we have to understand that we have
one kind of consciousness and other
animals and even plants have another
kind of consciousness.
So it's real.
It's a real thing.
The idea that they're looking back at
me,
I'm being metaphorical,
but I that they're aware of me,
um,
in the way that the,
plan is aware of that the bee is nearby
and does certain things sometimes to
trap the be and hold it there for a
longer amount of time to load it up with
pollen.
Um,
there are the world as we perceive it is
dependent on the particular senses we
have.
We've got the big five senses that you
always hear about and there's some other
littler ones.
Um,
you know,
how we locate ourselves in space.
We're pretty good at that too.
Um,
but other creatures have a different set
of senses and,
and therefore they live in a different
world.
So the beef for example,
can see ultraviolet light.
We can't see.
So if you could get inside of bees head,
the world would look very different.
And you'd see patterns like landing
markings on flowers in ultraviolet
colors that they can see that you,
you've never seen before.
Ditto.
They also can experience electromagnetic
radiation.
We can't,
you know,
it's all around us.
We don't feel it.
They feel it.
And the reason they do is a plant that
has a strong electromagnetic field
hasn't been visited recently by another
b.
So they know this is a good,
you're going to get a lot of nectar
here.
And,
um,
whereas if you,
if you're going by,
you know,
you're flying by a flower and it's got a
soft field,
doesn't have a big field,
it's probably just been visited by
someone else.
So skip it.
So they're living in a world where
they're perceiving cell phone radiation
and all,
all the kinds of crap we're putting into
the electromagnetic spectrum.
Um,
so,
so we have to realize that this is a
very specific world that we're
perceiving in our normal consciousness.
That is the one that we need to
perceive.
It's good for us.
[inaudible] we were designed for
reflecting our bodies and our upright
stance,
everything about us.
But other creatures are seeing a
different world.
And one of the interesting things about
psychedelics is you get some insight
into that.
You,
you sort of feel it and uh,
it's,
it's real.
I think in the sense of sure.
You were imagining there's still a leap
of imagination to understand the world
or octopus world.
That's a really weird,
where their brains are distributed over
eight arms.
Right.
And seeing that recent paper that was
just put out,
see if you could find it,
they're hypothesizing that octopus,
they might've come here from another
planet,
literally not,
might've been seeded by another planets.
Very controversial,
but it's from legit scientist.
And what they're trying to think of is
if it's possible that the eggs of things
traveled and
comments and somehow that came here
hundreds of millions of years ago.
And the reason being is that they can
alter their rna and that this is very
specific to a Octopi are octopuses.
Yeah,
here it is.
Octopus's came to earth from space,
frozen eggs billions of years ago.
I don't know if they would put it that
way,
but it's,
it's just a theory,
but it's a theory that's being bandied
about by legitimate scientists.
It's crazy.
You can do so many things that no other
animal can do.
Like instantaneously changed their
outside.
Yes.
To blend into their area.
Also each arm we can make its own
decisions without referring to
headquarters.
Really?
Yeah.
They have this distributed intelligence.
Wow.
And regenerate as well.
Yes.
Now they are.
They're really,
they're really crazy.
Um,
so this idea that there's something
relative about our everyday normal
consciousness that there are other ways
to experience the world is something
that psychedelics puts you in touch
with.
It was just reading this interview with
this physicist named Carlo Ravelli.
He's a theoretical physicist from Italy.
He wrote this book a couple of years ago
called seven brief lessons on physics,
very prominent guy.
And he was telling this interview or in
the Guardian that he got turned on to
physics,
uh,
during an lsd trip he had when he was
15.
And the interviewer asked him why was
that?
And he said,
well,
I saw for the first time that there
could be another way to think about time
in instead of,
uh,
you know,
past,
present and future that it might all be
simultaneous.
And that's how it appeared to him during
this lsd trip.
And he's,
when he,
when he was back to baseline,
he said,
um,
I,
you know,
I was asking myself,
why am I so sure this is the real world?
And that wasn't the real world and it
was just an hallucination.
And he said,
the world as it presents itself to us
right now here actually physics tells us
is not the real world that there are,
you know,
that space and time are curved.
That particles don't exist until they're
perceived by a consciousness.
You know,
all these crazy ideas of theoretical
physics.
He said,
I,
it suddenly seemed like worth exploring
that,
that the world as it presents itself to
us is not the only world and,
or necessarily the accurate world.
And I was very interested that a
scientist could develop that idea of a
beyond in the way you would think of a
religious person developing the idea of
a beyond that there's a scientific
beyond and there's a religious beyond
and psychedelics at least gives us a
hint that,
that those worlds exist.
And that was,
um,
that was very powerful,
powerful idea for me.
Have you looked into any of the
connections between ancient religions
and psychedelics?
Like,
uh,
any of the John Marco Allegro stuff?
Yeah,
I did.
I didn't go that deep into it.
I went in deep enough to know that there
are a lot of very serious scholars.
Um,
and,
and he,
allegro is one and Carl ruck another.
Um,
and Gordon Wasson,
the guy who kind of brought silicide
been to the west who I write about at
some length in the book,
really believe that it was a experience
of psychedelics,
which has been in culture for thousands
of years.
Um,
we know,
um,
whether you're talking about the Amazon
or Africa or,
and that these experiences may have
nurtured the religious impulse,
you know,
where do you get the idea of,
of,
beyond where do you get the idea of a
heaven or a hell,
if not from some altered state of
consciousness?
You know,
people talked about visiting the
underworld in homer's time.
Um,
so how did they do that?
Was it dreams?
Uh,
dreams don't have the authority that
psychedelic experience has?
Um,
there's something about psychedelic
experience that,
that,
uh,
has this,
it's not just an opinion,
it's just not,
it's not a fantasy.
It's something real.
It's objective truth.
This is William James called the noetic
quality of the mystical experience.
Um,
and that's certitude,
um,
comes from psychedelics.
And so it seems totally plausible to me
that at the very earliest stages of,
uh,
humanity,
if people were indeed taking
psychedelics,
this might explain how they came up with
these ideas.
Um,
there are other alternative theories and
it's not provable.
I just don't know how we would begin to
prove it,
but it seems plausible.
Um,
and you know,
the ancient Greeks had a psychedelic
that they used,
we think called the,
they called it the Kiki on k,
And they had an annual,
a ritual ceremony and it was the only
time in the year where you could use
this drug.
And it was a ritual to for diameter and
harvest or planting time.
And everybody in Greek society did this
and people,
it was,
you had,
it was secret,
it was called the mysteries,
the Eleusinian mysteries and you weren't
supposed to talk about it,
but there's a few accounts around and
people talked about visiting the
underworld,
making contact with the dead and um,
call ruck who's a classicist to be use
as well.
That was a,
that was a psychedelic potion and we
don't know what they were using,
whether it was mushrooms or something
else.
Um,
the Greek use of drugs is very obscure.
They only talked about wine,
but the way they describe what wine did
to you,
there was clearly something added to it
that they were adding other plant drugs
to their wine because they would have
these tiny little glasses.
And they'd take these big trips so we
don't know what it was.
Yeah.
Tiny glasses of one tiny glasses.
And they were very careful about when
you used it and,
and you know,
people would completely lose control and
it was just like,
no,
this isn't wine.
This is something else.
Yeah.
It is some sort of a psychic delicate
from grapes or know it too.
Well,
I mean,
we don't know some people,
Albert Hofmann who discovered lsd or
invented Lsd,
he thought it was air,
got that.
They'd figured out a way.
Air God is a,
is a fungus grows on grain.
And it was uh,
the,
the precursor chemical to lsd comes from
Aragon and uh,
air.
God is responsible for episodes of mass
delirium and European history.
You get a really wet year.
The air got grows on the Rye.
People eat bread made from it and they
go crazy.
Some people think the Salem witch trials
was came after a wet year and people had
absorbed,
these women had eaten air,
gotten,
we're having visions and things like
that,
which was interpreted as witchcraft,
which to them was a very thought there
were saying that the men had absorbed
that and thought they were under spells.
Maybe,
maybe,
maybe that too.
I just trip everybody's,
yeah.
So,
um,
anyway,
so,
so they just eat air.
God,
you're not going to be,
you could get gang green.
It's a myth.
It's not a clean chemical.
And,
um,
but the thinking of,
uh,
Gordon Wasson and call rock and they
were collaborators on this theory,
um,
was that the Greeks perhaps had figured
out a way to derive a pure chemical from
Aragon that could be made into something
very much like lsd.
But again,
nobody has succeeded and they've tried
for the last 20 or 30 years to take air,
got and make something,
you know,
through simple processes that the Greeks
could have mastered.
So it may have been a mushroom.
Um,
you know,
there's a lot of psychedelic plants out
there.
It's one of the mysteries of evolution
that,
you know,
dmt is like coursing through the plant
world,
thousands of plants.
So,
so I,
I do find it plausible that there is
some links between psychedelics.
I think psychedelics have have
influenced cultural history at various
points along the way.
And one of those may have been to kind
of nurture this religious impulse,
but again,
it can't prove it.
The Greeks spent,
uh,
some of the great Greek scholar spent a
lot of time in Egypt as well.
Don't know anything about that really.
I was wanting to try and figure it.
Yeah.
That was,
they were trying to figure out what
psychedelics,
if any,
the uh,
the Egyptians took and they'd never
really figured it out.
They made some connections to dmt that
is sort of loosely connected to their
worship of the pineal gland.
Yeah.
Right.
Where we've found DMT and rats.
Yeah.
The,
yeah,
the Cottonwood Research Foundation.
Yeah.
So you did that film about DMT,
right?
Yeah.
That's really interesting stuff that
there's been very little follow up on
that.
I mean this idea that there might be an
endogenous psychedelic like dmt I,
as far as I know,
we've only found it in the rat.
It's hard to look for it and the amounts
are really tiny.
Well,
they found dmt in people,
but they haven't found it in the pineal
gland.
If they haven't,
oh,
is that right?
Founded on the liver and the lungs and
that it's being produced that they know
that humans produce it and it's
indogenous but they don't know whether
or not the pineal gland does.
I said the pineal gland represents the
third eye of eastern mysticism and that
was what also they think what does it is
the eye of horus that they connected to
the pineal gland.
If you ever seen those comparisons pull
the comparison between the eye of horus
and the pineal gland.
It's essentially shaped like a cross
section of the pineal gland and I'm in
the temple and man,
see if you look at it up there and they
think somehow or another that this is
the,
the connection between these two.
There's a bunch of different things have
been written on this,
this connection,
because this appears in so many
different,
uh,
Egyptian hieroglyphs and they think it
might have some sort of a connection
between the portal to the afterlife that
they think the dmt experiences and the
idea of the Dao.
How would they,
how would they know?
I mean,
they didn't do they know about brains?
they,
well,
I don't know how they know how to build
pyramids.
How'd they know a lot of things.
I mean,
they did some pretty incredible shit.
Yeah.
We don't know,
you know,
because of the burning of the library of
Alexandria,
we lost almost everything.
We don't really know what they knew or
how they knew it,
but we do know that no,
that scholars from around the world
would go to Egypt to learn.
Well in general,
you know,
I have a more open mind about many
things since I've had these experiences
now than I did before.
I was a kind of staunch materialists.
It's normal.
I mean,
most people see silliness and hippies
and you know,
all these people that are out there
doing drugs,
trying to air quote find themselves,
you just see two seems like a foolish
venture and then you do it and you go,
oh okay.
There it's just being done by morons are
being described by morons cause it's
hard to describe.
It's also illegal.
So people shy away from it.
You don't want to lose your family and
get locked up in jail and all these
different things that people are
terrified of.
So you'd like,
look,
I'm not going to,
I'll have a glass of whiskey with
dinner.
And that's about it.
And also,
you know,
there's a kind of embarrassment.
I mean one of the really striking things
that I've,
I've been on the road now for,
this is my second week out talking about
this book and I have been struck by how
many people have had powerful
psychedelic experiences.
They don't talk to anybody about.
And I come along as a kind of,
I dunno,
credible person,
uh,
who's interested.
And they,
this is journalists too.
They turn off the tape recorder and they
say,
can I tell you a story?
And they had something happened to them,
might've been in their 20s or 30s or
earlier that changed the course of their
life.
And either because there was a stigma
attached to it or it was kind of had
this sixties kind woo think about it.
Or there were kids around,
they didn't feel comfortable and they,
so they kept it in this box labeled
weird drug experience,
but it's not just a drug experience.
So this is your mind.
You know,
the drug may have started the process,
but everything you see and in this
experience is the,
those are real psychological facts there
from your unconscious or from your
interpretation or your environment.
Um,
and you know,
it's not the molecule that,
that,
that ordered that for in this
experience.
Um,
as Stan Stanislav Grof,
who was one of the pioneering
psychedelic psychiatrist in the 60s said
that,
uh,
lsd
is an unspecific amplifier of mental
activity.
There's nothing packaged with the drug.
Um,
and that's important to understand.
So you had this big experience and you
put it in this box thing.
We're drug experience,
but when you take it out,
sometimes you find that there's,
there's a real gold there.
There's fool's gold too.
There's,
it's an interesting quote that quote you
just said cause because in actual
studies of the human mind,
under the influence of Psilocybin,
it's actually been shown to shut off
parts of the brain.
And so the,
the question is,
are we blocking off these constant
frequencies that are around us?
So this experience that's around us,
it is our own ego or our own mortality
or own desire to stay alive and protect
ourselves or whatever.
The various blockades that we put up are
those diminished by sales side and that
allows this ever present experience to
manifest itself.
It's exactly right.
The most,
the most interesting scientific finding
a of this current generation of research
is that when they image the brains of
people on psilocybin or LSD or Iowasca,
they expected to see fireworks,
right?
Lots of activity because the experience
has lots of fireworks,
but they found something that they
didn't expect,
which was a diminishment of activity in
a very important brain network called
the default mode network.
This is in the midline and it connects
parts of your cortex,
which is the evolutionarily most recent
part,
two older,
deeper sources of uh,
emotion and memory.
And it's a hub in the brain and the
brain is a hierarchical system.
And this,
this,
this is the orchestra conductor.
It's one of the neuroscientists put it,
it,
it's a regulator.
So what happens in the default mode
network normally?
Well,
it's very involved in um,
self reflection,
self criticism,
worry.
It's where your mind goes to wander.
It's involved in time travel,
thinking about the future or the past.
It's involved in something scientists
called theory of mind,
the ability to imagine that another
person has mental states and it's not
just Iraq.
Um,
it is involved in what's called the
experiential or autobiographical self.
The way we kind of take what's happening
to us and connect it to the story we
tell ourselves about who we are based on
the past.
And the future.
So it's,
you know,
if the ego has an address,
it's in the default mode network.
And what is the ego do for you?
The ego kind of patrols the borders,
right?
It's the,
it's what keeps out,
um,
you know,
things that are threatening to you.
It keeps,
uh,
it's responsible for the repression of
subconscious thought or strong emotion.
Um,
and it,
it,
uh,
it's a defense.
It's a set of defenses and psychedelics
appear to turn this off,
uh,
to one degree or another.
Take the default mode network offline.
When that happens,
to go back to your metaphor,
um,
the whatever is blocking the that's
blocking lots of information from coming
in,
from outside or up from below in your
subconscious that's allowed to flow.
And so you are getting more information,
um,
than you might otherwise.
And this is a metaphor that,
um,
aldous Huxley used indoors or perception
that consciousness is a,
is eliminating more than it's creating
its it consciousness is,
is reducing our experience to that thin
trickle of information we need to get
ahead to survive.
Um,
and that you,
you opened the doors or perception on
these drugs by turning off this network
and lots more information comes in which
can be overwhelming,
uh,
but also extraordinary.
I mean there's,
that's wonder
is there apprehension in writing a book
like this and describing these things,
like as you're writing it and you're
thinking about all these other people
that are sort of cynical straitlaced non
drug using folks who might admire your
previous work on agriculture
architecture or whatever and,
and you're sitting there going,
how do I,
how do I get this through without
looking like a guy who's losing his
fucking mind or it's going Super Woo
Depok trope Ron,
right?
Like,
how do you,
how do you do this and maintain your
position as a serious journalist?
Well,
I was nervous about undertaking this
project.
Um,
but I also came to think it was really
important and um,
that there was something here and that,
you know,
when I started this process,
Stan Grof,
the guy or I made reference to earlier,
he had said in the 60 something I
thought was really outrageous.
He said that the psychedelics would be
for the study of the mind,
what the microscope was for biology or
the telescope for us.
Uh,
astronomy.
This is a really outrageous claim to
make.
Um,
but as time's gone on,
that idea seems less crazy to me that we
are learning things about the mind that
the,
and that these drugs are teaching it in
a scientific context and in an
individual context.
Um,
so just because some people think it's
embarrassing or Wu is not a way,
is not a reason not to do it.
I have to find a way to describe it.
And you know,
I'm being a little speculative with you
talking about origins of religion and
stuff,
but the book stays pretty close to
here's what we really know and here's
what I experienced.
Um,
I'm a science journalist,
you know,
and um,
uh,
so I try to draw the line between,
now I'm speculating and now here's
something that we really know with some,
with some certitude,
but without question,
I had some misgivings about describing
psychedelic experience,
their legal issues there.
Um,
and that,
yeah,
I have a readership.
I have a big readership that you know,
is happy if I just keep writing books on
food.
But I had found something to,
to interesting to pass up and I've been
gratified that,
um,
you know,
I've been talking about this book on
like network television.
I didn't think I would be talking to
Steven Colbert about ego dissolution and
here we are.
And he actually got the best line off on
that whole appearance.
He said,
um,
uh,
he said,
well,
maybe the ego should be a controlled
substance.
I thought that was pretty good.
It is a great line is fast.
He's a clever boy.
Oh yeah.
So,
um,
so I found though that the,
if I was willing to talk about these
issues in my experiences,
in a matter of fact way mainstream
journalists would respond in kind.
And so I've been on the CBS morning show
and,
uh,
Terry Gross on fresh air and,
and we've had a kind of,
you know,
conversation where we're looking at
these as tools.
What are they good for?
What are they not good for without
getting caught up in the usual,
um,
uh,
craziness that's associated with these,
with these drugs.
And,
um,
so that's what I'm trying to do is take
that sixties crust off these things and
take a fresh look.
Well,
for someone like me who's been a
psychedelic advocate for a long time,
it was extremely exciting news that a
guy like you were stepping into the fray
because you're,
you're so well established and well
respected already that I knew your
approach on it was going to be very
clean and that I knew that people were
going to have to start looking at this
like,
wait,
it's Michael Pollan's looking at this
like this,
this might not be completely crazy,
but the cultural attitudes about
psychedelic drugs or drugs in general
were so childlike and our,
our view on drugs,
I mean,
I have a friend,
wonderful person,
talks all kinds of crazy shit about
people smoking pot and take xanax every
day.
It's like,
do people,
don't all,
I just need a glass of wine and Xanax
and I'm good.
I don't know why you people need drugs.
Like,
wow.
Like you're fucking crazy.
But our cultural attitudes on the
substances that are prohibited and that
are,
that are accepted,
there's so strange and they,
they,
because of our social standing,
because we don't want to be perceived as
foolish or reckless or in some sort of a
mid life crisis or what have you.
We were like these journalists that are
shutting the microphones off and wanted
to talk to you about these profound
experiences that they had that they
should be shouting about from the roof
rooftops.
I agree.
Look,
it's really to normalize this,
people have to come out of the closet.
Yeah.
And some do.
I,
I was talking to a journalist in Boston
who was the local NPR host and he,
he on the air live talked about his
experiences and how important they were
in shaping his identity and the
experiences he had in college.
So I think we're going to see more
people come out of the closet and uh,
and have this kind of conversation will,
and we can actually look at this
experience in the same way now.
Yes,
it's still illegal.
But the fact that there is all this
legal research going on,
it has created a space where you can
talk about it.
And I,
I'm interviewing all these people and
they're describing their trips and
they're,
you know,
they're very straight people and um,
and they've had profound experiences.
So I think the culture is changing.
I really do.
I definitely think it is with which,
well,
I hope so.
I didn't write it with that idea that I
had this authority that I earned and
talking about food and nutrition and
then I'm going to apply it now to drugs.
I don't think that way.
I was just like,
I'm starting from scratch.
But I do realize that,
and people scare me a little when they
say,
you know,
peep psychedelic.
People say,
you know,
you're going to do for,
for silicide been what you did for food.
So that's really different.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
or this woman,
I was speaking at Google in Seattle and
this,
this woman stands up and she says,
well,
after I read your book,
I had a,
I had a slaughter,
a pig.
I had to learn how to slaughter a pig.
You made me want to do that.
And when I was driving to work today,
I didn't think I'd,
I'd ever take Lsd,
but now or silicide but,
but now I feel like I need to,
I don't want to do that to people.
I don't want them to feel they have to
have this experience.
You can learn a lot about the mind.
This book is as much about the mind as
it is about psychedelics.
Right.
This is a book that uses psychedelics to
explore this really interesting mystery
call consciousness.
Um,
and it's also exploring the nature of
addiction,
the nature of depression,
all the,
all the illnesses that psychedelics
turns out to be very helpful in.
Um,
you know,
but I,
I'm not holding a brief that people
should do this.
Um,
I'm not an addict.
I'm not an advocate for psychedelics.
I'm an advocate for the research at this
point.
I don't know enough to say,
yeah,
everybody should do this.
This is what our culture needs.
You know,
I don't,
I'm not in that Timothy leary had,
you know,
I think,
I think we have a powerful agent that,
that there is good data now that this
can help heal people who are really
suffering.
And the other reason for the openness
that's going on right now,
that surprised me because I expected to
get a lot of pushback from the
psychiatric establishment.
Uh,
and I,
and I looked for it.
I called around,
you know,
I want to hear the critical voice on the
hopkins work and the Nyu work.
And when I kept hearing,
blew my mind,
it was like,
I remember calling the head of the
National Institute of Mental Health to
get what I thought would be a really
negative quote about silicide been
research and he was like,
no.
Then we have to look at this.
This is really interesting research,
former heads of the American psychiatric
association and the reason they're so
open to it is that mental health
treatment in this country is just a
mess.
I mean we only reach half of the people
who are struggling with mental illness
at all,
have any exposure to the system.
If you compare mental health treatment
to any other branch of medicine,
oncology,
cardiology,
infectious disease is accomplished very
little.
It hasn't prolonged lifespan,
it's not saving lives.
Um,
and yet we have,
uh,
you know,
soaring rates of depression.
Depression is now the leading cause of
disability worldwide.
There 300 million people with major
depression or treatment resistant
depression in the world right now.
Um,
and suicide rates are way up.
partly it's the vets,
but,
uh,
in general,
the taboo is coming off is come off
suicide and suicide is climbing rapidly
and addiction is,
we know,
is rampant,
so they need some new tools.
There hasn't really been innovation in
mental health treatment since the early
nineties,
late eighties,
with the introduction of the SSRI
antidepressants,
drugs like,
you know,
uh,
paxil and PROZAC.
Um,
they need some new tools and that's why
they're open to this.
And that's why I think it will be
embraced eventually by,
um,
by the medical world.
Well,
isn't it on the ballot in 2018 in
California?
They haven't quite gotten,
and they're doing their petition drive
right now and an Oregon too.
And um,
so I don't know that it'll get through
this time.
It's a weird item to put on the ballot
because actually a small minority people
know what silicide is.
When I on this show,
you're the first person who said the
ingredient in Ma didn't say the
ingredient in magic mushrooms.
You have some confidence that your
audience knows what suicide in his butt,
but it's an unfamiliar world to most
people.
So I don't know how people vote on that.
Right?
Yeah.
It may be premature is what I'm
suggesting.
Well,
it's all dependent upon getting the word
out.
I think if people understand what,
like the John Hopkins research or just
the anecdotal research that some of
these people have,
uh,
had these incredibly life changing
experiences.
But I think one of the things that
you're saying is I think very important
is that this isn't for everybody.
And that if you have problems with
normal consciousness,
this is likely not for you.
If you're one of those people that has
schizophrenia and your family perhaps.
Got It.
Yeah.
And in fact those people are screened
out of this research very carefully.
Yeah.
Because the Fredonia,
it's,
it's a real issue with people with a
psilocybin and Ma many psychedelics,
right?
Yeah.
What happens with schizophrenia is if
you are at risk for it,
um,
either for a,
because of inheritance,
um,
a psychedelic trip can set you off,
can be the trigger for a life of it and
other things can to a divorce your
parents getting divorced sets people
off,
go to graduate school sets people.
If you're someone who's probably going
to get schizophrenia,
any kind of mental trauma,
if it happens at that window,
which is in your early twenties,
in your late twenties,
I think.
Um,
and that's,
that's why we did see some cases because
that's the age people were using
psychedelics in the 60s of having their
first psychotic break.
So yeah.
So if you're at risk for that or,
or bipolar as well,
by the way.
That's right.
Oh yeah.
Marijuana can do it.
Also,
I think the,
the,
the numbers though mirror the numbers,
uh,
in standard populations when it terms of
like,
I think it's one out of 10,
like one out of 10 people have some form
of schizophrenia and that's mirrored in
marijuana use.
I didn't know that.
That's right.
I think it's the same.
I think the problem is,
you know,
it can exacerbate it or it can trigger
it or you know,
depending upon,
I mean,
everyone's biology's different
and everyone's,
uh,
the,
the way they absorb these,
these chemicals is different.
Yeah.
And you know,
if you are at risk,
something's going to do it eventually.
Um,
so,
you know,
we,
we don't have any evidence of someone
thrown into a situation of schizophrenia
or other serious mental illness as a
result of a,
strictly because of the psychedelic
experience.
It may have been the trigger,
but there might have been,
it was going to happen anyway.
Right.
We just don't know.
But in general,
if you've got serious,
if you have personality disorder,
if you have bipolar,
if you are at risk for schizophrenia,
they will not accept you into these
trials and you should stay away from
these drugs.
Yeah.
Um,
that,
that is a real problem with it being
prohibited.
The prohibition has really set back
research and understanding decades.
I mean,
we should have been studying this stuff
since the sixth.
We had 30 years of hiatus in the
research.
I don't know if another time where you
had a promising line of scientific
inquiry all through the 50s and early
sixties,
that's just choked off.
And for 30 years nothing happened.
I mean,
think of what we would know if we had 30
more years of research with these drugs.
It's crazy.
So now we're picking up the thread and
all that research is being resumed.
But your,
but your point about prohibition is
really important.
When you have prohibition,
you can't regulate something.
It's a free for all.
Um,
whereas if you did legalize silicide and
let's take as an example,
you could set rules.
You could say that it can only be
administered by licensed guides or in a
medical context or that no one under a
certain age can have it.
I mean it gives you a chance to regulate
and that's why it's Saner to,
to legalize,
not in a free for all kinds of way,
but in a,
in a very considered way then to have
the system we have now where people are
going to take the drug,
whether they should or not without any
kind of clearance.
Uh,
and by the way,
who knows what you're getting.
You,
you know,
you can also regulate the,
the strength and the,
um,
and in the case of Lsd,
you know,
in the 60s there was this period where
there was a lot of pure lsd around and
then the mob got an interest in it and
they started cutting it with speed and
all sorts of things and people got into
it a lot of trouble.
It's also the issue with scheduling,
like scheduled ones for things that have
zero medical value and that's where a
lot of these drugs find themselves.
Academics are all schedule,
which is just bananas,
especially Dmt w the old Terence Mckenna
line.
Uh,
everyone's holding.
Yes.
We all,
we all have dmt in our bodies.
We all have a schedule one substance
flowing through our veins,
which is the most asinine thing in the
world to make your body a schedule one
substance.
Yeah,
it is.
And the fact is that schedule one means
that these drugs have a high potential
for abuse,
which isn't really true with
psychedelics cause they're not addictive
and that they have no accepted medical
use,
which is now no longer true either.
Because these studies have shown that
they do have a medical
use.
Yeah.
So you know,
what I hope happens and what,
and what we're on track to see happen is
that these,
these trials,
these drug trials we'll expand.
There will be now phase three drug
trials,
which is the last step before FDA
approval.
If the results of those trials are
anywhere near as good as the phase two
trials,
the FDA will then approve psilocybin as
a medicine and MTMA which there,
which probably happened first.
They're looking at that too,
uh,
for use in treating people with trauma.
Uh,
and then we will be in a world where
they'll have to reschedule it a to two
or three.
Um,
you know,
the opiates are too,
I mean,
actually the drug causing most suffering
in our country right now in death is not
a schedule one.
It's a schedule too.
I think it's too,
it might be three.
Um,
and so that we may see this in the next
five years or so,
which is kind of amazing.
Well,
we've got to get someone like jeff
sessions out of there that requires some
fairly archaic ideas.
Yeah,
I agree about marijuana.
You know,
I thought that,
okay,
in this administration we're going to
have another backlash.
But one of the things that surprise me
is that their voices on the right,
uh,
supporting this research.
I'm seeing more of it.
Rebecca Mercer has given money to maps
the Multidisciplinary Association of
Psychedelic studies for their work on,
uh,
Mtma.
Um,
and Steve Bannon has spoken out in
approval of this research.
So,
and Peter Teal is,
um,
you know,
is investing in a psychedelic
pharmaceutical company that's getting
started in England.
So I don't think it,
it may not break down in the usual right
left way that we're so accustomed to,
um,
and that may give it some protection.
Well,
I think one of the things that'll help
is anyone who has a loved one that's
going through a terminal illness and
experiences these things and sees the
profound alleviation of anxiety and this
just lessening of the worry of passing
on.
And Larry Hagman was once on a,
like a real straight television show,
like CBS or Fox News or something like
that.
And they asked him about his life and
like what,
what makes him so happy?
And he said he had a profound acid trip
and you see the host going,
what?
He goes,
yeah,
well I took a,
a really powerful dose of Lsd and a,
it completely alleviated my worries
about dying.
And you know,
I remember seeing him on television
going,
wow,
they didn't know this was coming and
seeing this straight interview or just
trying to uncomfortably move past the
subject.
Okay,
well the guy from Dallas is a fucking
drug addict.
I didn't know what to do with it,
but he was so warm and smiling and I
believe it was a piece on his house
because he had some crazy off the grid
sort of life and some ecofriendly house
and all solar powered and used a well
and all this different things.
And uh,
you know,
they were asking him what made him so
happy and I'll never forget that he was
saying
when he did acid wants a really powerful
experience.
Cary grant also,
uh,
had 60,
um,
guided LSD trips in the late fifties,
and he gave an interview in 1959 to a,
uh,
a Gospel,
very famous Joseph hyams who was the
gossip columns.
So that time saying this had changed his
life.
He was using a low dose.
They were,
there were a lot of psychiatrists in la
who were giving a low dose Lsd to people
in their normal talk therapy sessions to
essentially it was called psycholytic
therapy cause it was mind loosening
therapy and it would give you more
access to your unconscious and make you
be able to talk about things that you
might otherwise feel very defensive
about.
And he had 60 of these sessions and he
said he was born again and he said that
it had made him a much better actor
because he no longer had an ego.
Uh,
he wasn't crippled by his ego,
but then he also said,
and it made me irresistible to women.
Sounds a little egotistical,
have no ego with chicks love.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Are you aware of any of the research are
doing now with ketamine and depression
and they're there?
There's a lot of people that are getting
administered pretty high doses of
intravenous and intramuscular ketamine
for depression,
including one of my good friends,
a Neil Brennan.
He's gone through it several times and
talked about it on the podcast and said
it was a real game changer.
There's a lot of excitement in
psychiatry about ketamine,
ketamine as an anesthetic.
Uh,
it's,
it dissociative,
uh,
it,
it makes you feel separated from your
body and that helps with pain.
Um,
so it's,
I don't know if it's strictly speaking
the Psychedelic,
it's certainly not a classic
psychedelic.
It doesn't work on those brain networks.
Um,
but,
uh,
it is legal because it's been used as an
anesthetic for years and it's relatively
safe as an anesthetic compared to some
of the others that are used.
It's the one they use.
If,
if,
um,
you know,
you come into the trauma center and
you'd been shot or something,
you need surgery and they don't have
time to check whether you're allergic to
any other drugs.
That's the safe one to give you in a
crisis would carry it around during
times of war.
And then that's turned to people on the
field.
Yeah,
they all,
yeah.
Um,
and uh,
this,
they don't really understand how it
works,
but they give people what is kind of a
psychedelic dose.
They go way out there.
It's fairly brief,
I believe,
and many people with depression have
found relief.
It,
it's not permanent.
Um,
they need to,
it looks like they need to do it again
every six months or something like that.
Uh,
but it seems to kind of reset the brain
in a way that,
um,
many people are finding helpful.
And this is all legal.
I mean,
you can,
there are ketamine clinics,
uh,
where you can go,
and psychiatrists who are,
who are administering it to people.
Um,
so for people who are struggling with
depression and can't wait for psilocybin
therapy to be approved for depression,
which is still several years away,
ketamine is,
is worth exploring.
What about,
did you look into that at all?
A little bit.
Um,
I begin is a psychedelic from a root of
a tree that grows in Africa and it has
been used specifically to treat opiate
addiction.
Um,
and that's God,
if we need something now a tool to deal
with opiate addiction are clinics in
Mexico where they one down there.
Yeah.
You opened it after he had his own
personal problems with pills.
He had a back injury,
got hooked on pills,
was really struggling to get off of
them.
Went to Mexico to do Ibogaine caught
completely off of it felt amazing.
Realize like,
oh my God,
I have to help people.
And then opened up his own clinic.
It's amazing.
I mean there's a bunch in Guadalajara,
I don't know where he is,
but there is,
um,
there is uh,
you know,
people doing it.
I don't know exactly what the legal
status is in Mexico,
whether it's legal or just tolerated.
Most drugs have been decriminalized in
Mexico,
including LSD and mushrooms and a lot of
other things to try to do something to
curb the violence from the drug cartels
at least keep it nonlocal right.
You know,
a lot of the violence is coming from the
drug cartels,
getting money to ship everything to the
United States with our use.
It is very strange that our insistence
on prohibition is actually funding one
of the largest drug and violence
epidemics we've ever seen in terms of
like what's happening south of the
border.
Well,
yeah,
and think about Columbia to the civil
war in Colombia.
It was funded by our card or cocaine
interest.
Um,
so I began as a very intense drug.
It is,
uh,
did you do it for though?
I didn't,
I didn't.
Uh,
and I wouldn't do it,
I don't think because it has big
implications for your heart and yeah,
and in fact when you,
so it is more toxic to the body than the
so called classic psychedelics and it
can last like 36 hours.
It's a very long trip.
It's really intense in these clinics.
They s you have to be on a heart monitor
while they're,
while you're doing it.
Um,
and that was like,
I had a,
I have a minor heart issue that,
that made me stay away from Mtma,
which is an amphetamine.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I mean I'm the kind of guy who goes to
his cardiologist before he has six
psychedelic trips to check it all out
and make sure it's okay.
I have something called Afib,
a atrial fibrillation,
which,
um,
you know,
his Ma you can manage with,
uh,
with medicine,
or there's a procedure you can get it
just to kind of occasional irregular.
Yeah,
it just happens sometimes.
Um,
but my cardiologist warned me off of MDM
may because it can raise your heart
rate.
Although I've subsequently learned,
if you take a Beta blocker,
uh,
it's okay.
Um,
so anyway,
I have,
I've never experimented with that.
But anyway,
in light of that,
uh,
I,
I would stay away from,
I began,
but I'm really curious about it just
because we have such a crisis with
addiction.
Uh,
but silicide been is,
is being used successfully for
addiction.
I talked to,
uh,
smoking people,
lifelong smokers who broke their
addiction with a single or two silicide
and journeys.
And they had extraordinary
stories to tell.
Um,
I didn't understand how you could have
one trip and then give up a lifelong
habit.
And I asked people about this and,
uh,
I talked to this one woman,
she was about 60,
and she was an Irish book editor,
and she,
uh,
she said on her,
I said,
so what happened?
How'd you,
how'd you stop?
She said,
I,
uh,
well,
I first I grew wings and I flew through
European history and I visited,
you know,
the site of Shakespeare's globe theater.
And I saw the Salem witch trials and I
died three times and I saw my body a
rising from a funeral pyre on the
Ganges.
And I realize the universe was so
amazing and there were so many
incredible things to do that killing
yourself with cigarettes seem kind of
stupid.
I was like,
I could've told you that.
Wow.
But see,
it goes back to that,
that noetic quality that the,
she had a perspective on her life she'd
never had or on the universe and that
she believed that smoking was stupid in
a way she knew before,
but it didn't have that conviction.
That rock hard review revealed truth,
conviction.
And I heard that for many people and I
asked the doctor about it or the
psychologist who was running the study
says,
yeah,
everybody has these Duh moments and
they're on their psychedelic trips.
Then ended up being transformative.
Did you have a dumb moment?
I had a lot of insights.
Um,
I don't know if I,
yeah,
I did actually.
I have different trips.
Did you have while you're doing,
I had a six or seven.
I,
so I just a couple to silicide trips.
One guy did one,
not an LSD trip,
guided a couple IOWASCA circles.
And then,
um,
I had a really weird psychedelic call,
five Meo DMT,
which is the smoked venom of the Sonoran
desert toad who figured that out,
you know,
she gets some kind of prize.
Um,
but um,
that's a pretty,
pretty potent,
very potent and thank God short acting.
I'm short lived.
Um,
it was,
it was actually a horrible experience
that really,
that was my worst.
Yeah.
I had a great experience.
So what was wrong with it?
So I,
you know,
you take like one puff and before you
exhale,
um,
I was,
I mean this is a synthetic version two,
right?
I was taking the venom.
Um,
you're shut out of a cannon and there's
no lead up,
no warm up.
It's like fun.
And I felt like I was actually like
strapped to the outside of a rocket,
you know,
going through space and through clouds
and like the g forces pulling down my
cheeks.
And it was just this mental storm
without any nothing to Orient Myself.
There was no space,
there was no time,
there was no self.
And um,
it was just unendurable this punishing
roar and my years and someone who had
done it said,
eventually it's like a takeoff and you
get into orbit and it,
and it's,
it's very nice at that point.
But what happened with me is I had the,
I had the,
I mean I felt like it was like,
the metaphor I use in the book is like I
said,
I can't explain this.
You can't tell a story without place,
time and character.
Right.
I had none of those.
Um,
it was just this in Kuwait energy and I
said it was,
it was like the before the big bang.
You remember that?
Well,
obviously nobody does.
Yeah.
But there was pure energy and no matter
yet,
and no time yet.
I mean,
that's where I was.
And um,
it was horrible.
It was terrifying.
And I thought I was dying,
but then you,
you come down,
it was kind of a suborbital flight.
And then I started coming down and
suddenly I could feel,
oh,
I've got a body,
you know,
it was touching my legs.
I have a body and like,
oh there's a,
there's a floor,
there's their space.
And then there's time and the,
and the universe kind of reconsolidated.
And I had this feeling of incredible
gratitude,
not just for being alive,
which all of us have had at one point or
another,
but that anything existed I was,
I was grateful for the fact that there
is something and not nothing,
because I'd seen what nothing was lying.
And so in that sense it ended up kind of
positive,
but you wouldn't want to go there to
have that experience.
So subsequently somebody said to me a
very experienced psychonaut who I was
telling the story too.
He said you didn't have enough.
I was just going to tell you.
Really?
Yeah,
cause you only took one hit.
Usually take three,
you take three and the rocket lied.
The rocket ride leads you somewhere.
It takes you too.
You take three,
three,
three in a row.
Take a same time,
blow it out.
Take a big one below it out.
Take a big one,
and as you're taking the third one,
you're already seeing the world
crystallize in front of you had already
starts turning into geometric patterns.
He put the pipe down,
lay back in the chair and just shoot off
to the center of the universe.
The terrifying thing is you cease to
exist like,
yeah,
it's the one drug that I've ever taken
where you don't,
you're not there anymore.
Yeah.
Uh,
even an end dimethyl trip to Maine,
which is the difference between five
methoxy diamond field trip to me is just
an oxygen oxygen molecule attached to
it,
but [inaudible] and dimethyltryptamine
is incredibly visually stimulating.
Five methoxy is not,
it's just white.
It was white.
It was definitely,
I don't know how I could have taken
three hits because I hadn't excelled.
The first one when I was gone,
you said,
well,
I don't know what you're,
I was,
I only did the synthetic version of it
and you're doing this.
And the person I know who
did the synthetic version had a very
different experience and they felt like
they were installed in the firmament as
this happy star,
but I didn't get there.
So it,
who knows I did something wrong.
Okay.
I don't think you did.
I just think you had a different
experience.
And I mean I've obviously,
there's gotta be some sort of chemical
different,
you know,
you're probably getting other things in
that frog venom as well as pure dmt.
That may be it.
Yeah.
I mean there's all,
I don't know the answer to the fucking
frog spit do you,
by the way,
no carbs.
No frogs were harmed in the making of
this drug.
It's excreted on the outside of their
body and what most people can milk them.
Yeah.
You,
you rub them on a glass and then let it
dry off and then you scrape it off the
glass and crystal get,
yeah.
You just kind of squeeze them.
And then it sprays the glass and
overnight it turns into it looks like
brown sugar.
Yeah.
It's an amazing thing.
You're the first person who knows
anything about it that I've had that who
is going to be able to buy it used to be
able to buy legal time recently 2011 jug
of this shit.
Oh my God.
Offline.
Uh,
I bought it from some company,
American chemical company or something
and they send it to you.
And I had enough to get the entire state
of California high for several days
because it doesn't take much,
but it's not something you want to do
very often.
I don't think it has the same kind of
healing properties because you're not
bringing back information that's usable
bag a lot.
Yeah.
I brought back a lot about myself and
one of the things that I realized as I
was,
I recorded what I would do is post trip,
I'd hit a tape recorder right when I
became conscious again and start talking
about the experience and what I remember
saying about the five methoxy dmt
experiences.
Like,
as I'm trying to recount what happened,
I feel my ego trying to retake,
hold the situation and even use words in
a way that might impress you with my
ability to describe things or as you
know,
as a professional comedian too,
I was aware that like a lot of what
you're doing,
you're saying things in a way that's
pleasing to people so that they get
excited about hearing you talk.
And I was very aware of that while I was
doing that.
I'm saying,
I'm saying I'm trying to explain things
that are not possible to explain because
the words that we're using were all
invented for a world that doesn't exist
in the DMT dimension.
And it's once,
once you break through,
it is so profoundly alien that any words
liberating.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well in a way,
I mean it may,
it may be really truly realize that we
are in a soup of,
of Adams and that it's not,
yeah.
There's not like Michael Pollan,
Joe Rogan and Jamie Vernon in a room.
Here's a wood table.
There's oxygen in between.
No,
this,
we're in a,
an universal stew of particles.
Yeah.
And it breaks those particles down,
or at least it gives you a view into
that and you cease to exist,
which is the most bizarre thing because
it's so similar to end and
dimethyltryptamine chemically,
but so different in the fact that you're
not there while you're doing regular d n
and dimethyl trip to me,
which is the active ingredient Iowasca
if you'd done that,
the pure version of it.
No,
not the pure version.
The pure version is like a very short,
much more intense Iowasca experience.
I've never done Iowasca.
I've only done the dmt version,
but the injection or no smoking it,
but when you,
what you get out of it is you're there
while this is happening and you're just
blown away and you're like,
I can ask drew and I don't see,
but there's all these entities are
trying to calm you down,
relax,
take it in,
settle down,
settle down.
They're all trying to calm you down and,
and,
and alleviate.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's weird,
you know,
and they're also fucking with you.
Like they give you the finger.
Like I had a bunch of jokers that were
like dancing around me,
giving me the finger machine elves to,
I don't believe in that thing.
I don't know what that is.
Like Mckenna had those experiences of
machine elves.
I never saw,
I saw it.
What I described is complex geometric
patterns that are made out of love and
understanding.
They,
they seem to me to be like the building
blocks of the soul all around you all
the time.
Like some just gigantic,
impossibly large,
infinite well of souls.
Just these things dancing around you and
they were,
they were never one thing.
They would be one thing for a second and
they change into something else and they
change it to something different and the
more profound the experiences God,
the more profound the next one would be.
And they kept saying like,
look at this,
look at this.
Like the,
but the words weren't real words.
That's the other thing.
It's like I'm saying the words,
look at this and I would have that in my
head,
but I never heard anybody say it.
It was almost like it was triggering
those,
the,
the concept of those words in my mind,
right,
right.
It's,
it's pre or post linguistics,
some of these experiences.
So when you,
you,
you asked about dumb moments though,
but um,
you know,
I had one where I had this like
cascading since flood of love tour.
I was thinking about my family,
I was thinking about my son and my wife
and my parents and,
and you know,
it sounds like so banal and one of the
things that happens is that these
platitudes that love is the most
important thing there is.
Okay.
Take that for,
except that could be on a hallmark card,
but suddenly it's infused with like,
yes,
that is so profound.
And you know what?
It is profound.
But we have these defenses against
seeing it that way because we've heard
it so many times,
you know,
a sense of banality is just from
repetition,
but you're put back in touch with,
you know,
a platitude is a truth that's been
drained of all emotion and the emotion
comes back and it becomes really
powerful.
So I,
there's a whole riff in the book about
platitudes and like,
oh,
we have to rethink these platitudes so
it can make you sound like an idiot.
Um,
but is that right or is that right?
You know,
and I,
and I actually think the experience is
more truthful than the ironic cynical
perspective that we bring to it in our
everyday lives,
which is a defense against powerful
emotion and being overwhelmed every day
by wow,
love,
you know,
whatever it is.
So you,
you,
you end up revaluing those kinds of
things.
And that the,
so that was a really important takeaway
from me.
The other was having an experience of
ego dissolution that which can be scary,
can also be very blissful if it's then
followed by emerging with nature or
other people.
And I do think that is the therapeutic
agent in these,
in the people who are
healed,
that our ego does keep us from
perceiving certain things and it
enforces really destructive stories.
We tell ourselves like,
I can't get through this day without a
drink.
I'm unworthy of love.
Uh,
you know,
the voice of self criticism all.
And we get trapped in these loops.
And especially as we get older.
And that's one of the reasons I think
psychedelics are actually more valuable
the older you get because we are
creatures of habit.
And by now we have these mental
algorithms that organize our,
our,
our response to everything.
And sure,
that's very efficient.
Um,
but it blinds you to experience it,
blinds you to the everyday wonders and
Psychedelics,
you know,
softens those habits and,
and,
and helps you get out of those grooves.
And for me that was really useful.
And uh,
it's only,
I think it's the experience of ego to
solution that allows you to,
cause your ego enforces those habits and
you get a little break.
There's a beautiful metaphor.
One of the scientists I interviewed in
the book,
a Dutchman working in,
uh,
in imperial college in London.
He said,
think of your mind is a hill covered in
snow?
And your thoughts are sleds going down
that hill.
And after a while,
after a lot of thoughts have gone that
hill,
there'll be these grooves.
And then getting to get deeper and
deeper.
And to a certain point,
you can't go down the hill without
slipping into those grooves.
That's who we are is where like,
you know,
at this age and,
um,
what psychedelics do,
he said his is flattened the snow,
lots of fresh powder and you can then
take the slit anyway you want to go.
That's a great way of describing it.
I've always talked about predetermined
patterns and grooves that people fall
into.
So it's amazing hearing him say it that
way,
but that's a much better way of
describing it.
Like snow,
the sliding these thoughts down,
these already existing patterns.
That's amazing.
That's,
you know what you said about love and,
and,
and being cynical.
That's so important too,
because there's something that's
something that people are,
they avoid sincerity.
Like there's something about it that it
makes you too vulnerable or too open to
criticism or to open to ridicule.
And we're worried about being sincere.
And I do think that that's one of the
primary benefits of psychedelics.
Yeah.
Well,
we live in an ironic culture and we
defend ourselves against strong
experience or self exposure by adopting
this stance.
That's ironic.
And,
uh,
cool.
And,
um,
psychedelics is not a cool experience.
It's the opposite.
Well,
it's cool when it's over.
Yeah.
But yeah,
it's,
it's serious stuff.
And,
um,
how much did you pay attention to
Mckenna's theory?
Uh,
about,
uh,
the evolution of the human brain of the
stoned ape theory that yeah,
I looked at it,
um,
but I found I didn't find it persuasive.
And in fact,
if you press Terence Mckenna,
he didn't find an entirely persuasive,
it's a very,
it's an interesting speculation.
It's kind of a mind game.
I don't
see how I can see how uh,
psychedelics would influence the mind
and,
and create new ideas,
new memes,
um,
and Mike contribute to language.
Um,
but how does it get into the genes?
That's what I had to change the genes
cause he said it changed us at the
genetic level.
I see.
Psychedelics is having had a profound
effect at the level of cultural
evolution that there are lots of
interesting innovations that people who
had psychedelic experience introduced to
our culture.
We talked about religion earlier.
That could be one.
A,
I had a wonderful interview with Stewart
brand,
the founder of the whole earth catalog
and his insight.
He had this profound insight,
um,
during a psychedelic trip on the roof of
his house in North Beach.
And he saw the curvature of the earth in
a way he hadn't before.
And he said,
God,
if we could have a phone,
this is 1966,
we had never seen a picture of the earth
from space yet.
And he said,
if we had a picture of the earth from
space,
and we could see it as this round space
ship,
that would change everything.
Because if you think of the earth is
flat,
as most of us instinctively do,
it's endless.
There's endless resources.
Uh,
you don't have to worry about limits in
any way.
But if we had that image and he
realized,
we,
I have to start a campaign to get NASA
to turn the cameras around.
They're on their way to the moon,
show us the earth from space.
And he said,
I'm going to make a campaign.
I know,
and he's,
you know,
this is not an LSD.
I'll make a button,
very important medium in 1966,
I'll make a button.
And what should the button say?
It should be a little paranoid to get
people's attention.
Why haven't they shown us an image of
the earth from space?
Yeah.
That's what he would do.
And he started a campaign.
He started selling these buttons and the
campaign got in the newspapers and it
goes viral as you know,
as viral as you could get in 1966 and
two years later and NASA produced that
image and he put it on the whole earth
catalog and that image galvanize the
environmental movement.
So it's those kinds of memes that
psychedelics introduces into culture and
that changes culture,
that image changed culture.
Um,
and I think there are hundreds of them.
I mean,
Steve Jobs talked about his use of LSD
is very important to his,
uh,
formative experience.
And in fact,
there's a whole tradition of computer
engineers going back to the 50s using
lsd that I wrote about in the book.
So,
but I don't see how we were selected
genetically because of the,
there was an advantage to the people who
were taking a lot of psychedelics.
Um,
that's where he was at me.
Maybe I'm misrepresenting it.
His theory is that it coincides with
climate change and these lower hominids
experiencing experimenting with
different food sources.
So as the rain forest receded into
grasslands,
they started experimenting by flipping
over cow patties and finding grubs and,
and perhaps even mushrooms that were
growing on these cow patties.
And his theory was that there's a bunch
of different benefits.
One low doses of silicide but have been
shown to increased visual acuity.
The hunting dogs in certain cultures.
Yes.
Yeah.
Make you a better hunter,
make you more in tune with what you're
doing,
um,
that it would make you more,
it would a central nervous system
arousal including sexual arousal.
It make you more horny,
which would make you productive,
appropriate more often.
And that the,
the very unusual effect that psilocybin
has on the mind could have led to
language and could have also led to the
expansion of neurons.
That language to me,
brain out of cultural evolution.
Sure.
Yeah.
The doubling of the human brain size
though,
was it?
The particular thing is that it
coincided,
according to the Mckenna,
it's been there.
There's a lot of people that disagree
with him,
but his brother makes a very compelling
case for him and his brother Dennis,
who's still alive and was a brilliant,
brilliant guy.
He talked about it on this podcast.
He talked about his take on the stone
Arab or a stoned ape theory
scientifically,
why he believes it's really what
happened,
but that it does coincide with the
change in climate of these,
these,
you know,
eight black people trying out different
things and that the doubling of the
human brain size over a period of 2
million years,
it was like one of the greatest
mysteries in the entire fossil record.
Their alternative theories.
I mean,
I wrote it up.
One of my last big all coincided maybe
cooking with fire.
Yes.
You can explain the increase in the
brain size because you get more
nutritional value from cooked food,
the throwing arm,
uh,
the,
the desire to hunt all these different
animals and the calculating all these
different ways to do that.
And communication.
I think there's cooperation.
A bunch of coinciding fat and it may
well be that,
that,
uh,
people were eating everything right?
Our ancestors,
it's amazing what they ate.
And uh,
and no doubt they ate psychedelic
mushrooms and no doubt.
I mean,
he also believed that language was a
form of synesthesia in the way that
synesthesia you can smell a musical note
or something like that,
that you're taking a sound,
a meaningless sound,
uh,
you know,
um,
and,
and you're attaching it to a concept
that maybe that happened on Psilocybin,
but a bunch of ideas that never panned
out.
He was,
he was,
he was in high or audibly creative
person and yeah.
And,
uh,
and,
and they're all,
you know,
really interesting to think about some
of them.
I think you could probably discredit
based on what we understand about genes
and evolution,
but others are just really provocative.
That's where his brother comes in.
Yes.
His brothers,
his brother's a scientist,
strict scientists.
It doesn't,
he doesn't tolerate any of the woo woo
and straight and he's skeptical of his
brother's idea is to open.
Yeah.
I mean loved his brother,
but he was like,
oh,
there's a lot of things that weren't
really accurate,
but also terence Mckenna to,
we'd say,
well,
you know,
just putting these ideas out there.
The guy was a constant pot user.
He was constantly doing psychedelics and
really good talker.
I mean,
he would have a podcast now,
right?
Oh,
it would be amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
I promote the shit out.
I would too.
Yeah.
I mean,
he was a fun guy to listen to talk and,
uh,
there's a,
there's a podcast called the psychedelic
salon that my friend Lorenzo hosts that
has pretty much every terence Mckenna
lecture and speeches ever done,
available for free.
You can download it.
And Lorenzo is taking these and
digitally remastered them to,
the sound is better.
And it's really awesome that,
that,
that he's got this resource.
But the idea that these,
uh,
lower hominids experienced ancient
hominids experienced,
experimented rather with silicide,
but then this was what advanced culture
or advanced language advanced their
understanding of each other.
It's a very,
very compelling idea.
Yeah,
it is.
And I think,
I mean the way I think about drugs like
second alex in evolution in the same
way,
like in genetic evolution,
radiation causes mutations and some of
those mutations turn out to be really
valuable,
you know,
purely by accident.
Some great new trait is introduced to
the species and it increases fitness and
that person or that individual lives on
in the cultural realm,
psychedelics are like radiation there
mutagens they create change variation
and that advances cultural evolution.
Um,
all that variation,
all those wild ideas,
99% of them are stupid and useless.
I'll bet.
But that 1% can change the world.
Yeah,
absolutely.
All right,
let's let you go cause I know you gotta
get Outta here,
but I wish I had more time because we've
got a lot more to talk about.
But I'll come back in town.
Please do.
And the name of your book.
Once again,
how would it change your mind,
what the new science of psychedelics is
teaching us about consciousness,
dying,
the addiction,
depression and transcendence.
And is it available in audio form as
well?
Yes.
Yeah.
I and I recorded the audio book.
Excellent.
I'm so happy to hear you say that.
I hate it when other people read
people's books.
I did too.
And they told me my first couple of
bucks,
now you've got to have an actor to do
it.
And people complain.
They said,
that's not you.
So now I insist under it.
It takes a week out of my life.
Each time.
It's,
it's not easy,
but,
uh,
I'm very proud of this audio books,
so I hope people will check.
That's awesome.
Thank you very much,
Michael.
Thank you,
Joe.
This was a pleasure.
Michael Pollan.
Ladies and gentlemen.